hey what's up guys my name's samuel
leeds i'm a property investor and i've
been investing in property now for over
10 years
and every single sunday what i do is
take
your questions your property questions
and based on my
last over a decade experience in
property i'll do my best to
answer your property question to help
you on your journey to financial freedom
so last week we had some really
interesting questions which i'm going to
go through right now
while i'm answering last week's
questions if you get a question
pop up comment it below and i'm going to
be answering your questions
next week also if you like my youtube
videos please do
smash the like button also don't forget
to subscribe turn the notification bell
on
let's see what happened last week daniel
dan what if you
but a tenant in a short term like one
month
and then he decides not to leave
how do you evict them they are not on
any contract thanks love all your videos
great content okay daniel firstly
i'm gonna tell you how to make sure that
doesn't happen again
and then in your situation i'm gonna try
and give you some advice best i can so
firstly never never never never never
put a tenant in your property without a
contract that is
really really risky because if that
happens
like you're saying it has or you're
worried that it might you're in really
really
bad place because if you've got no
contract with the tenant
then they're not even a tenant they just
live in your house
so if you want them to move out but you
haven't got a contract
you haven't got any terms you haven't
got any agreement
they've not agreed on anything so it
makes it impossible for you to
evict them so i know it sounds like
terrible right now but you are in a
little bit of a bad place
i would suggest that you speak to a
eviction company that will be able to
give you specialist advice in your
situation but you could
be in hot water over the next few months
were you trying to sort this out if they
just refuse to move out
i hate to breathe the bearer of bad news
uh you need to speak to
a victim now i'm going to put a link in
the description of an eviction company i
think is evict them now dot code uk
but to stop it happening again make sure
that you have an agreement so
if an ast contract is normally for a
minimum of six months but you can get
short let agreements specifically for
these types of stays
which you really really need to do even
if someone's only moving in
for like even on airbnb if you're moving
someone into a property just for one
night they've still
got terms they've still got an agreement
that they sign they're not just a person
in your house
almost like a squatter so i hope that
helps speak to a victim now
let me know how it goes daniel all the
best what else we've got craig craig
goldie hi samuel in scotland you can't
do lease option agreements
instead it's delayed purchase and it's
compulsory to the date you agree
would you avoid delayed purchase
agreements in scotland due to not
knowing if the house prices will rise
so craig yeah i wouldn't i probably
wouldn't do a delayed completion
and set the price like in five years and
just hope that house prices go up
because
whilst they might they might go down so
if you have to buy at the end of the
agreement
i'd only do a delayed completion if
you're able to force the price up so if
you're buying a property then you
know that by doing x y z you're about to
push the price up
then great do a delay completion carry
out the works push the price up and then
complete
but if it's just oh well let's just see
what happens and hope it goes up
then at least optional agreement is
better and if you're living in scotland
maybe consider doing a lease option
agreement just on the very very far
north of england
on the border of scotland but i would
that would be my general advice not to
do
a delayed completion unless you know
you're gonna be about to push up the
price it's just too
risky there's always risk involved in
buying the property but you want to
de-risk it as much as you can hope that
helps
charles did you ever get your hands
dirty on any of your jobs
i know my hands look like kind of baby
hands i did
i really really did i don't get my hands
super
dirty very often now but actually you
know what when i started out in property
i worked on a building site for six
weeks i was i became a plasterer i did
lots of plastering
um so in terms of hands-on work i did do
that
and also just getting my hands dirty by
getting really stuck in you know moving
the tenants in
moving the tenants out i did that for
years i've been an estate agent i've
been a letting agent i've been a
plasterer i've been a negotiator so i
have got my hands dirty
now i still get my hands dirty when i
have to
but here's my general philosophy and i
hope this helps
i think that whenever you're doing
something you need to be thinking am i
learning
am i earning so you should probably get
your hands
really dirty at the beginning because
you want to learn everything and then
once you know what to do then you're
going to
employ people they're going to do it for
you but you know what they're doing
you get the role so but for me right now
if i was to go and
if if there was a some plastering that
needed doing for me to go and do that
plastering myself even though i can do
it
wouldn't make sense financially because
my time is too valuable i'd rather pay
someone else to do it but also in doing
it i'm not even going to be learning
because i already know how to do it i'd
probably be rubbish now anyway but
that's kind of how i look at stuff so i
hope that helps charles
get your hands dirty in the beginning
make sure you've got good people around
you so you're doing it but you're
in a safe environment and then replace
yourself as often as you can in business
you always want to be replacing yourself
great job ben marshall hello samuel i'm
a big fan my question is i have ten
thousand pound save right now and i want
to invest
all of it all of it great this will be
my very first investment as i'm in my
early twenties
my thought was to put it into the stock
market for now as i really don't know if
i can invest in property with a small
amount of money like this
what is your advice for someone young
employed and really wanting to invest
grow my assets common which will develop
my income statement
okay ben i listen i don't know loads
about the stock market but i probably
wouldn't put it in the stock market if
you want to be a property investor and
the fact that you're on my channel
asking me property questions you
probably do
if you put that 10 grand in the stock
market actually 10 grand gone for the
time being now yeah you might be able to
put it out
but i would probably use that 10 000
pounds
i mean i don't know your situation
exactly you say you employed but i would
probably use that ten thousand pounds
and put it into something like a rent to
rent business and rent to rent is gonna
give you good cash flow but you're also
gonna be getting your hands dirty so
you're gonna be learning the skill of
property you're gonna be getting some
nice income
and then with your experience and with
your the money that you're making then
maybe consider doing something like a
joint venture once you've done that
but i wouldn't put it into the stock
market especially if
you're not educated because investing is
always risky unless first you've
invested in yourself so maybe use some
of the ten thousand pounds to invest in
yourself
you know take a take a 100 pound course
or something in property
i've got lots of options available that
you can do with me you can see in the
description
but invest some of in yourself maybe
start rent a rent business
learn build up your knowledge and build
up your brand that'll be my advice good
job though and great to see you winning
in life in your 20s
paul from the uk hi samuel i have i
currently have a buy to let with around
160 thousand man equity
and 50 000 pound savings i'm hoping to
add another buy to let some time in the
next year
would you use the savings or release
equity from the existing buy to let
and what options are there to add maybe
two or even three by to left with my
current situation
thanks paul great job paul so you've got
one bite to that already you've got
fifty thousand pound savings you've got
equity of 160.
i probably wouldn't take it all out at
once
i wouldn't refinance if you've got 50
grand
because why not use the 50 grand first
on something and leave the money in the
house
if you're gonna refinance when you do
refinance
my advice is to is to probably not take
a little bit out because if you take
let's say you've got in equity and you
only take out 50 grand
and then you invest it and it goes
really well and then in another six
months you want to take out another 50
grand you're going to really find that
difficult because
refinancing regularly it's not like the
money's in the bank and you can just
pull it out
it's hard because when you refinance
you'll be probably fixed into a few
years and then it's going to be early
penalty fees for getting a new refinance
out so my advice
probably would be for you paul use your
50 grand savings if you can
unless you need that for something else
invest it in property and invest in
something a bit bigger you've already
got a buy to let at least one you said
so to answer your question though is it
possible to get two or three more buy to
let's
absolutely but i would probably try and
do something a little bit more
profitable don't be one of these
landlords
that just grows a big portfolio for the
sake of it you've already got one
make sure that the next one is better
than the first one make sure that the
figures are better maybe it's a bigger
deal
and then once you've got your bigger
better deal you can see the figures
coming in
then refinance and do something bigger
and better again
so you're in a good place though so i
hope that helped a little bit if you've
got any follow-up questions on that
comment again and i'll answer again next
week tyrone
saxton says hi samuel i watch all of
your videos
and i followed all of your videos since
you were on the itv i don't remember
being on the itv maybe i was on the itv
i don't even keep up any more
i truly believe i'm one of your biggest
fans
respect buddy i appreciate that however
i have never attended your course
i would only want to come to the course
for a picture with you
fair enough come down dude we'll grab a
coffee and you can get a picture with me
backstage anyway my question is i'm 27
years old
and i have in the last 28 days purchased
a four bed hmo property
i have filled four rooms up with
students in 12 days
and received deposits from all i will be
receiving
1 700 a month from each student and from
september
however i would like to buy a second
property by pulling out
the from this two hundred thousand
pounds hmo property
even though i own it outright i have
been told that i need six months minimum
experience
and 25 savings of cash in the bank for a
second house
how do i get a second house as a
mortgage broker said i'm in an unusual
situation thanks sammy i look forward to
the response
wow well firstly buddy great job on
buying your hmo and filling the rooms in
12 days and everything like that that's
absolutely phenomenal
i don't know where i can totally answer
your question um because i don't know
you say you're in an interesting
situation i don't know your situation at
all
it might be that you just have to wait
six months to pull the money out
in which case that's fine and to be
honest i wouldn't recommend tyrone
especially if you've not
been to my courses yet i hope you've
done some of the online stuff but i
probably wouldn't recommend you've just
bought one hmo it's been a couple weeks
you've filled it and it's going great
i probably wouldn't recommend quickly
buying another one anyway i would say
learn learn from this property
give it three months six months anyway
and then see
the money coming in get get used to
managing a property
so you don't know even how long those
tenants are gonna last those tenants
might hate the property and move out
so just i would just breathe
i would probably find a more um if your
mortgage broker is not giving you good
answers and he's saying oh no you can't
you can't you can't i wouldn't want a
broker like that i'd be trying to find
another broker
and it sounds awesome sounds great but
if you have to wait six months to pull
your money out
wait six months to pull your money out
don't rush this is a long
game not a short-term game you tyrone
are clearly someone that's a very bang
bang bang bang action taker which is
great
and sometimes i need to say to people
come on act act you've just bought a
house
literally you've just rented all the
rooms out just breathe
and if you have to wait six months wait
six months and then refinance
but i don't know if that answered your
question at all but i hope that helps
but i look forward to seeing you at
crash course real soon
also you need to join samuel 365 where
we can actually talk we can mentor you
i think you'd really really get a lot of
value from that's 95 pound a month
and i'll leave that in the description
as well good job tyrone
okay bence hi samuel is it allowed to
pay the bridging loan
deposit using a personal loan i would
like to take the bridging loan for my
new limited
i would fund the limited with the
director loan but the money will come
from the personal loan
okay bence it is possible yeah bridget
bridging loans don't care where the
deposit comes from mortgage companies do
bridging loans don't so i don't think
you'll have any issue doing that great
job all right one last one
oh tyrone again tyrone saxton go on
tyrone you're an awesome guy so i'll see
i'll answer your next question as well
i've recently just got one 4-bed hmo yes
we heard we love that each room are
responsible for paying for their own tv
license which i've just found out
that i find is crazy in itself however
how can i make the communal areas more
appealing and what can you add to the
properties and make tenants day longer
any tips
get used to my comments now i have
finally worked out how to do it
legend okay dude firstly you've got to
join samuel 365. it's in the description
all right serious serious serious
because you're gonna you're gonna love
it um
how do you make ten stay longer a few
ways number one make sure that you've
got super super super fast wi-fi
tenants living in the hmo if the wi-fi
goes bad they get
really irritable so just make sure
you've got the best wi-fi
secondly make sure that you've got a
really good hmm management company
because if if the tenants have got
problems queries in the hmo
they do take quite a bit of management
so if they've got an issue and and no
one's responding in time
then they're going to get irritable and
potentially move out if you're managing
it yourself that's okay but just make
sure that you're accessible
that you're a good landlord if something
needs fixing you fix it
um other than that i mean maybe get a
cleaner maybe get cleaner to go in once
or twice a month and clean all the
communal areas
i don't think you mentioned do i need to
do anything to the communal areas i
don't think you do
in fact what i've found with hmos is
they actually don't even hang out in the
communal areas that much anyway
i think they're very much in 2020 we
just want convenience
we want speed cleanliness
good customer service and we want to be
left alone
hmos they it used to be everyone will
hang out in the communal area
now people just want space they'll be
they'll be in there in their bedrooms on
that on their ipads
rather than watching tv together so i
wouldn't do too much in the communal
areas
just give them what they want which is
speed convenience
affordable accommodation be a good
landlord keep it clean and ask them
ask them do a survey once every six
months and say hey how's it going
you can do the first survey right now
how's it going what can i do to make
sure that you're all happy
get them to fill it out and then every
six months send them a survey how's it
going
how's the accommodation how's the
service from and and that's a really
powerful thing
so folks hope you enjoyed that tomorrow
i'm excited about tomorrow today is
sunday i'm filming this like
you you when you're watching this it's
about an hour after
i actually filmed it today's sunday
tomorrow's monday
and tomorrow i'm going to be doing a
response video
to channel 4 joe lysted joe lyson did a
show about me
which was on that wasn't itv that was
channel 4
on friday at 8 pm last week a couple of
days ago
and i'm doing a response tomorrow i
can't wait i think you're gonna really
enjoy it if you're not subscribed
please do subscribe right now turn the
notification bell on
and enjoy tomorrow's video i'll see you
there thank you so much
smash the like drop a comment subscribe
peace out